I was surprised when even when Obama
tapped you to be Secretary of say Oh was
I didn't you know why you know why I
thought it was difficult because you
were fully ready to be the president in
the United States right if I was you
would I want to be sitting with Obama
and in the back of my mind I'm saying I
can be doing this I don't I mean not
that secretary no but that's the
difference between running against
somebody who you respect right so he
gets elected he asked me to come see him
he asked me to be Secretary of State and
he basically said look we're in a mess
that's right the economy has gone
totally down
we have problems around the world he
said I need your help I can't do both
I'm gonna focus on the economy because
we're in a terrible shape
there's intact great but I need you to
go travel around and try to restore our
relationships that's an executive and
that's why I was honored to serve with
him because first of all he is secure
right not threatened by you being
Secretary of State at all and also you
know we did run a really close race we
had overlapped in the Senate for a few
years but we ran a really close race and
it was touch-and-go people forget this I
actually got a few more votes than he
did yes he got a few more delegates than
I did and but here's the thing you were
you were ready a senator you had been a
first lady and you weren't the first
lady who sat there matey you would the
first lady but I remember Hillary care
yes they were really into getting some
kind of protection for children right
and of course you were vilified for that
but it's crazy to me you had all this
experience and then this upstart a new
senator but you know there he had
enormous talent it serve your husband
and and and and the two best orders
unbelievable both of them right and and
they they just had whatever that magical
charisma was it wasn't phony
entertainment it was deep positive
security integrity I know what I can do
for this country give me a chance
very adult very Adele but that's a rare
gift right it is I mean you used to get
the oh your voice isn't right
your hair isn't right you don't know how
to speak properly blah blah blah blah
blah yeah you know and and so you know
did you ever sit there and say to Bill
how the hell are you connecting like
this like when you watch Shiva mean it
is quite a remarkable skill it is a
truly remarkable skill in varrock habits
yes but the campaign seems to rely on
that and that's not what I'm looking for
a good executive to run the country well
I think you know look you got to get
both in the same package all right
obviously I think both of them were
really good presidents and had to clean
up a lot of messes both of them and and
left the country stronger than when they
found it which should be the criterion